hey guys welcome back to middle ground
Before we jump in we've got a huge
announcement a lot of folks have been
asking for this for years
we're finally giving you the first-ever
jublee podcast called radical empathy
that's right we are really proud and
excited to share it with you guys it
actually features an interview with
somebody in this episode so stick around
till the end and we'll tell you more
about it for now I don't think I know
for a fact that they'll open your this
flat it's like we have this picture of
reality that's a big puzzle piece and
then one of those pieces worked with
just wasn't bidding I'm always open to
having a discussion with someone who is
holding a wrong belief like this
I'm not the evidence is so much nobody
wants to be a flat earther but if he
showed me incontrovertible evidence I
would definitely go back who wants the
ridicule
I'd like to tear them to pieces
[Music]
I'm Jim Underdown executive director of
the Center for inquiry West in Los
Angeles and the chair of the CFI
investigations group I'm Spencer marks
one of the senior members of the CFI
investigations group science advocate
I am medina yari I'm a theoretical
physicist and with the University of
Airline I am Wendel Walton I am a chief
learning officer for a young startup I'm
Shelly Lewis I'm a graduate of West
Point critical thinker and jumped out of
airplanes my name is Dan glatman my work
is dan the water man and the drinking
water filtration industry and a truth
seeker
well I've been a Christian for 30 years
so the Bible is a flat earth book you
have to take it literally like for
example in Isaiah when it talks about
how the earth is like a clay wet wax
seal that stamped with upturned edges
that's just not some fancy story that's
a simile it is like right absolutely and
in Nice daya talks about - and I'm a
Christian he who sits upon the circle of
the earth there's a difference between a
circle and a ball well exactly if you
look at the original Hebrew it means
disc there's over 200 scriptures in the
Bible that point to a platter so this
notion that you need God or some higher
power to create the earth or the
universe is very old and was initially
posited by people of a pre-scientific
age since then we have learned quite a
bit about the universe coming into
existence when that happened modern
humans don't get their cosmology they
don't get their physics they don't get
their knowledge of the universe from the
Bible or any ancient text it's sort of
like the God of the gaps once you know
people used to believe that lightning
was God's wrath and throwing these
lightning bolts but once we understood
it was a natural process God Frank a
little bit more because now we couldn't
attribute those lightning bolts to God
we had to attribute that to the real
science and the other thing to the point
about the Bible specifically for me is
why is that one particular text the
correct one you choose to believe that
and that's fine but there's so many
other writings and so many other books
so why weren't they correct why is just
the the Bible correct
well what you'll find in a lot of these
ancient religions is they're all flat
earth really
Jen's all their cosmology goes back to
being a flat earth with an enclosed
system so it's not just the Bible that
teaches this it's many different
religious books so one problem I have is
to trying to explain phenomena happen in
nature
by holy books those are religious books
those are not books of science and it is
wrong to infer or deduct scientific
readings out of those books my name is
Wendell I am a logical biblically-based
and scientific flat earther I didn't
start out and no one starts out as a
flat earther but I had a lot of
questions so I actually got to the point
where I had to go out and and put my own
eyeballs on it so we went out to an
observation at Salton Sea and things
just didn't add up down there so we've
gone back probably a dozen times and I
can guarantee you that there is no
curvature over distance
[Music]
we have the advantage of information
today that's outside of channels two
four and seven and the few networks that
are corporately owned it's pretty easy
to say YouTube isn't research but when
you spend enough time you're picking up
quite a bit and with the discussion
groups panels we've gone against
opposition we've opposed ourselves
surprisingly enough Flat Earth is its
own worst enemy so it's not that easy
for us to come to consensus and we find
that consensus is orchestrated and not
actually at scientific in any way you
know my grandfather used to tell me
growing up never believe anything you
read in the newspaper right he told that
to me now what the age of the Internet
it's like you know how much of this
misinformation are you getting there and
when you have like eyewitnesses taking
video of something you do have to take
everything with a grain of salt that's
why because of my my multimedia
background I knew that all that stuff
could be faked you know take it into
Photoshop take it into After Effects
okay this is at the core of the issue of
why there are so many Flat Earth
believers out there right now the
problem is the information from someone
who decides to start a website or
produce a YouTube video is not reliable
when I have a toothache I go to a
dentist my car breaks down I go to a
mechanic when you have questions about
cosmology you should go to an
astrophysicist you should go to a
physicist you should go to people who
have spent years and years studying
these ideas not some 6 minute YouTube
video there is a percentage of people
that if they saw a YouTube video that
was not within their scientific chops to
refute on the face of it would believe
anything out there one of the things I
will say is nasa.gov has their own
documents out there that we get to vet
which is through the Freedom of
Information Act and would you agree that
NASA documents if they're on display
that we should be able to go and
research inside there NASA is not true
thing that the earth is flat well they
say you should read what NASA says and
you should listen to I would love to
seek your NASA evidence earth it's only
they're contradictory issues okay
never bring us here we're all familiar
with the earth rise photo right the
earth is rising over the moon we're all
familiar with it that's the NASA you can
go out to the NASA site you can download
the original right I already know what
you're gonna ask so you bring up the
luminance on it and you can see where
it's cut out and pasted there they're
showing us doctored images that are
clearly doctored the Blue Marble is a
very famous image from 1972 when you
talk to the artist from NASA his name is
Robert Simon he talks about exactly how
it was created from data and it's not a
photograph whatsoever he added the
highlight is you take you know on your
phone most phones have that panoramic
image when you do that you're taking a
series of picture and the phone cleverly
says yeah how its presented presented is
a real flow when NASA takes real photos
and they either clean them up for color
or they stitch them together so it's one
large image it doesn't mean they're CGI
you're talking about composites I'm what
you call a globe denier you could even
get me into a virtual construct if I
can't find they work the borders myself
it appears to me to be a stationary
plane as opposed to the vastness of
infinity of space I would find it to be
a nice plane where we have a localized
Sun and our environment thrives there
you know these these particular people
have misled us on television this is a
brilliant opportunity to speak
we've been suppressed censored by
mainstream media alternative media is
that's just a thing of beauty for me
well they're certainly think they're
educated and they're following quite a
bit of beyond the university system what
we call scientism right scientist
obviously is the belief in what's what's
written where we tend to be exploring in
the field with physical properties not
theories of any kind we're using actual
measurements that are calculated not by
our guidelines but the guidelines of
science as we know it I can only hope
they're uneducated as opposed to
disingenuous well that's the other thing
too because we know that it was on a
large scale the government has been
disingenuous and they're there they're
pushing a narrative right so it's it's
hard for us I'm and I'm sure that you've
met people too it's like look are you
just you haven't looked into it yet or
are you a shill
are you are you part of a disinformation
campaign I don't think you guys are
uneducated I think you're wrongly
educated I think the problem with what
I've seen in the Flat Earth crowd is it
it's not there undereducated but they
instead of looking at evidence and
letting the evidence guide to where the
ultimate conclusion is they start with a
conclusion and then they try to
cherry-pick evidence to support their
pre-drawn conclusion they cast away all
the bits of evidence that actually is
contrary to their beliefs I think that
you're very well educated as well as you
are Jim Mayola the best education of all
exactly and he paid for it too but more
and
or professionals are coming on board
they're certain to question their
reality so the thing of it is is once
you start to really look take a hard
look at the evidence and you are
unafraid of just standing for the truth
wherever that may lead you then people
end up becoming flat earthers I'm hoping
to be able to tell our side of the story
from the inside out so many times flat
earthers are depicted from the outside
in and I want to be able to share with
others empirical data that proves the
earth is now what we've been told
[Music]
so when I was 12 years old I went to
Space Camp and I met Alan B Shepard oh
yes yep and I wanted to be an astronaut
and I wouldn't be the first woman to
walk the moon so for me I'm a globe er I
went into this completely wanting it to
be true and my husband told me he saw
this thing about the fake moon landing
and I was like you're absolutely crazy
there's no way that the moon landings
are fake and then in 2010 my husband was
killed and so I never really developed
that until around 2014 when Flat Earth
kind of came back up and that was sorry
and that little voice inside my head
said remember the fake moon landings
remember when that was brought to my
attention and then I started really
critically analyzing that and I would
say you know just looking at that
evidence if they can lie about the moon
landings they can certainly lie about
pictures and satellites and other things
than so I started going down that rabbit
hole of studying so that was my
influence does it take to make a liar
right and being ridiculed for being
inquisitive it's pretty tough on us I
wouldn't say that I've changed my mind
because my mind isn't set NASA is is
solely designed to change my mind it is
from its inception the from its
discovery has been a television program
it's been a space program to sell us on
something that they've yet to actually
show us show me a globe spinning with
clouds and a moon show me home
and I think I could shut up quite easily
I think I could shut up the timing of
your conversions is interesting to me 20
years ago the Flat Earth world was tiny
and insignificant enter the advent of
the internet YouTube online discussion
groups all these new available places
where you could find information about
this is true that the evidences you
looked
were not robust evidence and the sources
you used there were not reliable sources
again but my problem is that and I like
you guys that you are very skeptical but
at the same time you are not skeptical
about your belief system that you got
first you think that that's my
foundation for why I believe the earth
is flat and I'm telling you you're wrong
I have evidence that proves it's flat
what type of evidence are being misled
we're being deliberately less misled by
mainstream or what's your evidence we
see too far we see too far we should not
be able to see I live in Dana Point okay
I can see San Clemente Island which is
60 miles away and you see a ship which
is going don't you always talk about the
ship that goes over the curvature of the
earth I love it
so science has said that when I see a
ship go out of my field of view it's
going over the curvature of the earth
practice yes but then I bring my p900 up
and guess what I can zoom it back in so
is it going over the curvature of the
earth
absolutely the bottom part of the ship
yes you shouldn't see the top of it if
the earth were truly flat there would be
really hardly any limit you'd be able to
stand at the top of the Empire State
Building and look towards Chicago a mere
thousand miles away and see the lights
of Chicago at night very thick i I've
been to astronomy since I was 10 it's
faulty logic it's completely faulty
logic
one of the big things I do is
investigate extraordinary claims like
flat earther ism or ESP or all sorts of
different things the earth is
undoubtedly a globe and not flat this is
well supported by gobs of science what
is the question
scientific consensus is possible
possible anything is possible
I mean anything is possible I've got it
I've got a tremendous issue with
consensus and peer review I've been
spending a lot of time arguing the other
with people that argue the other side
and I found that surprisingly consensus
always wins it was shocking to me that
the group with the majority has an
incredible advantage as scientists
flat-earthers truthers punks we're an
incredible disadvantage let's talk about
scientific consensus for a second you're
never going to get a hundred percent of
anyone there is scientific consensus on
a global earth there scientific
consensus on evolution a lot of big
issues the word theory do you know what
a theory and science is an extremely
tough and a fact let me in fact don't
mistake this word theory you are in
science it's not conjecture it's not an
explanation in science the word theory
is the highest level that you can give
something because it's so well supported
what about a fact is a fact it's it's
well the fact you would call it you know
why do you know why because in science
there's always room for improvement
there's always room to find better to
tweak and find better information so
that is how science works
it gets better refined over time as
opposed to flatter Theory which never
gets refined it simply as what it is new
ideas have limited access to media
and limited exposure until we're in US
University curriculums we will continue
to appear uneducated well that's not
true in the history of science we had
many occasions that it the ideas it was
not welcomed by the society Einstein was
one of them Galileo Galileo was one of
them but if your theory is an authentic
one and it can be go through this
hardship of scientific method eventually
I used to believe that science was after
the truth right they just we all just
want to know what the truth is science
has been trying so hard to divorce
itself from the idea of a creator when
God's intent was to create science to
lead you to him you know sometimes
things seem supernatural that we are
able to explain later through you know
science okay I understand but there are
other things as well that are
supernatural that go beyond the natural
that we can always explain through
believing in a creator right this is my
big issue with science scientific
approach and non scientific approach you
are absolutely right in science we are
after the truth and we are hoping by
each day we're getting closer and closer
to the truth we never get there never
well I know that's true for you that's a
science that's that's you guys
you think you do have the truth now
let's look at the evidences as you were
mentioning you do have the conclusion
let's find the evidence this science
doesn't work that you're referring to
Jesus who many billions of people do not
believe including myself and many more
billions do so so who's right of course
when you say that we start with a
conclusion and then try to match
everything to make it work like that to
me is complete dishonesty that is not
true at all this is what you are doing
you know you're not you're making that
assumption which I think there's a lot
of so do you make assumptions or not the
science the assumptions the science no
we're sure we do make assumption but
based on things
are well supported by proven Andry
proven by we don't have tell me how you
isolate gravity if gravity we don't you
show me the scientific method how you
isolate gravity
you're like a human I kind of feel like
I want to develop some of this stuff a
little bit more it feels high-level but
I feel like there's so much that I
haven't really even touched base on well
I mean I certainly didn't think that
anybody was good on either side was
gonna flip well there's still time
there's still time I have hope for you
wonder and you know it I don't know Dan
you know it's certainly I'm glad is the
civil discussion sir yeah the greatest
moment in television history
[Music]
so I mean obviously any organization can
be wrong with certain things and they
may have individuals that lie or deceive
or something but as a general
organization they're looking for the
truth
yeah the idea that NASA and the
government is lying to us about the
shape of the earth is the height of
conspiracy theories in order for this to
be true the literally hundreds of
thousands of people who at some point
over the last 50 or 60 60 years would
have to have to be somewhat complicit in
this
and nobody spills the beans at all is on
the face of it completely unbelievable
the private does not know what the
general is doing there's
compartmentalization happening all the
time of course so it wouldn't be that
far-fetched has the government ever lied
to us is really the question at stake we
all agree on that right and we oh
absolutely they're not lying about
anything they're completely transparent
everything is true I'm sorry I'm sure
you were talking about a government now
you're talking about an asset but this
agency is scrutinized by thousands and
thousands of scientists around the globe
you are dealing with smart people
believe me you are I don't know so it is
very hard to do that once or twice maybe
not for the whole time
[Music]
what is the proof hundreds and hundreds
of pounds of moon rocks and dust and we
have distributed those freely to PhD
scientists around the world and not one
of those geologists have said we faked
and collected on the ice in Antarctica
and in the Arctic as well they're sort
of collected that you don't have to go
to the moon to get moon rocks as a
matter of fact all US Air Force
photography prior to 1958 shows a Flat
Earth only NASA shows us is lying to you
my not myself is we have a laser
retroreflector on the moon that we're
using now we still use to this day you
it's sitting there you can find to the
inch how far away the moon pictures of
home that only is my question to you is
why why would all these honest
hard-working people perpetuate this
massive fraud why would they do this
what's the benefit okay the benefit of
it they make fifty two million dollars a
day follow the money no the little guys
one thing when you say all okay he
didn't start out that way and NASA was
not founded the proof and earth was a
globe it had nothing to do with the way
they were found you go are you sure yet
positive really yes
somebody has to be a voice for reason
and somebody has to be a voice for truth
it's it would be a fantasy to believe
that I would change anybody's mind from
the other three however if there's
somebody sitting on the fence and this
is the first introduction to this debate
perhaps they'll hear the reasonable
voice and say that makes more sense than
having this pizza shaped earth
I used to be a ball Arthur everything
you say right now is completely what I
used to agree to so I completely
understand where you're coming from for
me I think the the correct way to do any
kind of investigation or to examine
things is by literally putting yourself
in that mindset of the other person so I
do do that I disagree with your position
but I completely understand from your
perspective worried what you're saying
the trouble I have understanding your
perspective is in the modern world
unless you live in a cave somewhere you
have to believe in science implicitly I
met a flat earth or a young woman who
said I don't trust anything that science
does and that's a problem because human
beings can't replicate the whole body of
science every single generation at some
point you have to trust what's already
been discovered and proven and move on
to the next thing otherwise we're not
going to advanced at all I mean when you
turn that key ignition in your car you
expect the car to start out and not blow
up and not blow up because science put
you in that position so it's really hard
to understand how people would know in
their hearts that science achieves
wonderful things and then just jumping
ship when it comes to this other issue
we're not drawing conclusions we
understand the mechanisms that made that
car work there is no theories and no no
disputed conclusions involved there it's
not a good analogy can I admit a great
compromise that we have to experience
being against the grain people is we
have to literally sit in a group and
decide whether or not we can afford to
have an opinion and that's that's tough
I actually I I agree with you there
because we're the same thing I mean I
think skeptics
go through this and atheists go through
this I don't believe in God when I'm
around religious people I take a chance
socially when I tell them I'm an atheist
so I know it takes some courage to
follow your beliefs and I appreciate
that
but I think I've done a lot of research
and that venue too and it's not
something I choose to believe in it's
something I have to believe in based on
the evidence see what I get from you
guys is that seeing is believing so how
come you believe in God or Jesus you
haven't seen neither of them right I've
seen evidence so well exactly so we are
looking for evidence there are many many
other evidences for earth not being flat
my point is that these are these
experiments clearly show that the earth
is glow and you don't need to go outside
the globe it's a few only you want
evidence if you're saying that you look
only to see something then I dispute
your belief system in God and Jesus or
Jehovah or Buddha or azeris Torah or any
Bible is not the only reason I know what
the shape of the earth is a new people
that's fallacy it's not policy actually
it is not some theoretical physicist
what I'm doing is the combination of
string theory and cosmology so we try to
understand what happened during the Big
Bang after the Big Bang or even before
the Big Bang
well I hope I would be able particularly
to the young generation to convince them
that first they should think critically
and don't believe anything they
shouldn't take anything for granted
look at the evidences and examine those
evidences and throw away those claims
that are not evidence base science not
to put it down but when you're talking
about rocket science this is very
difficult for the majority of people to
understand and it's designed that way
and so in a lot of ways
hiding behind rocket science is similar
to religion if you look at the Catholic
Church back in the days only we can
interpret the Bible you have to listen
to what we say
so in a lot of ways we're getting that
same notion from science that says only
we can interpret what these numbers are
you just need to trust us but then when
we actually do go and test some of their
equations and they don't work does that
beg the question for us to go and test
it ourself absolutely I would say you
know one great thing about science is
its predictability let's form some
moment for a short moment assume that
your model this Flat Earth model is
correct
I don't know what does it buy for us
what does what does it predict for us so
my question for you guys would be next
time bring me something from your theory
your model that you can predict
something which the globe earth model
cannot predict then I would change my
mind and we just say that don't believe
anything that I've said you got to do
your own research and I think what
you'll find is that you'll see that a
puzzle piece doesn't fit and the only
way you're going to do that is if you
put your own eyeballs on it I don't
blame people for being skeptical I'm
skeptical about a lot of different
things I applaud that instinct in you
but you have to go beyond just not
believing in something ask the hard
questions
ask what qualifies a YouTube or a book
author anywhere else you're getting this
information what qualifies them to make
wide-ranging comments about the shape of
the earth look anybody who can overturn
Einstein or some major theory is going
to be eventually written in the halls of
science for the rest of their lives but
they have to come up with the goods
they have to show good science-based
evidence that what they say is true and
they have to withstand the test of time
and peer review and the rigors of the
scientific method thank you guys for
watching this episode of middle ground
that's right we know that one of the
biggest requests we get is we just want
longer episodes we wanna know more about
these stories we want to hear more about
the middle ground so we created a
podcast called radical empathy where we
can do just that Shelly from this
episode actually sat down with me and we
had a conversation about her beliefs and
how she came to be a flat earther
it's amazing you have to listen to it
but don't just take our word for it
we're gonna play you a little sample
right now alright this is John regalado
sitting with Shelly Lewis and we are
here to talk about beliefs okay I have
studied that the earth is flat mmm and
I've come to the conclusion that I agree
with that
this episode is amazing there's our
first one ever and you can find it
anywhere you can spot mine and Spotify
an apple stitcher wherever you listen to
podcasts but if you love it please let
us know in the comments there and also
give it five stars because if you guys
love it we're gonna do even more this is
just a big test yeah we'd love to do a
whole season of these for you guys so
thank you so much for supporting us we
want to keep making new things for you
and until there
you